yesterday the u.s. women's soccer team
defeated the team from the Netherlands
to win the World Cup yeah very nice
yeah and despite the loss the
Netherlands team still celebrated
because they have health care their
party went longer actually this is cool
this is the second time in a row the
women's team has won the World Cups
second time in a row yeah I love that
yeah yeah the women's team has done so
well the u.s. is thinking of getting a
men's team I'm right with that one let
me say about the men's team the last
time the u.s. men's team meddled at the
World Cup was 1930 yes to put that in
perspective in 1930 Herbert Hoover was
the president and Joe Biden was a
senator
you